with an 85 audience score on Rotten
Tomatoes you'd think the flash would be
killing it at the box office
unfortunately this isn't the case and
we're here to tell you why after one of
the most chaotic and controversial
production Cycles seen in recent years
the flash is finally in theaters
hi
superhero flake was released on June
16th in the United States backed by a
hefty budget of 200 million dollars
worth an additional 100 million dollars
reportedly being spent on marketing as
of now according to recent box office
reports by deadline and variety it
doesn't look like Warner Brothers will
be celebrating the film's returns
anytime soon in the United States The
Flash only earned around 55 million
dollars during its first three days and
projections for the future are not
looking good internationally the movie
seems only to have captured around 75
million dollars overall The Flash has
only made about 139 million dollars thus
far definitely not what studio heads
were hoping for this may come as an
awkward surprise since the film was
being talented as one of the best
superhero flicks ever made prior to its
release with comparisons to The Dark
Knight being brought up earlier in the
year very poor choice of words ahead of
its release a movie had several
high-profile supporters naturally DCU
boss James gurnard Monumental praise for
the flash alleged lead some Crews
personally professed how much he loved
the film to director Andy musketti so
what went wrong simply put the flash was
severely hindered due to the nearly
countless allegations against Ezra
Miller with multiple arrests and
accusations of assault allegations of
grooming Miners and felony burglary
charges the accounts against the actor
appeared endless before the film entered
his promotional phase asking even the
most Ardent comic book fan to get
thrilled about a long-awaited superhero
flick is a tall order when the main star
is constantly making headlines for all
the wrong reasons of course Warner
Brothers worked hard to Shield the film
from the immense controversy aside from
attending the Los Angeles Premiere
Miller had next to no involvement in
promoting The Flash Sasha Kanye who
portrayed Supergirl was a prominent
interviewee leading up to the film's
release and of course a movie's trailers
were quick to put an emphasis on the
multiple returning Batman The Flash
featured Ben Affleck donning the cow
once more and also saw Michael Keaton
reprise a role for the first time since
1992's Batman Returns you want to get
but
let's get nuts clay said to the official
release smaller cameos were also hyped
muskete revealed Nicholas Cage would
appear as Superman before the movie was
released though he later claimed this
was an accidental leak as fun as all
these appearances and Easter eggs might
be for fans as of Miller's name is
simply proving to be too cumbersome
despite the glowing and well publicized
praise the flash received prior to
hitting the Silver Screen the movie
seems to be getting a lukewarm response
from critics with a score of 66 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes The Audience score
was much more positive sitting at around
85 percent and Cinema score gave the
movie A B in addition lupa's own Dominic
Griffin assigned the movie A middling 5
out of 10 rating these certainly aren't
the worst scores especially for a
superhero movie however a film with the
amount of baggage The Flash carries
needs to be great it needs to inspire it
needs to drum up endless excitement
ensures The Flash needed to be
borderline perfect while an average
Marvel film might have fared okay with
these reviews The Flash most certainly
does not have that luxury for about a
decade now superhero fans have been wary
of DC films while Warner Brothers has
proven they can knock it out the park
with some of their properties their
latest films have received little
Fanfare or worthwhile praise Black Adam
was released in October 2022 and despite
boasting Dwayne The Rock Johnson and the
strong supporting curse the film faulted
at the box office and received little
praise from critics you didn't make it
in March 2023 despite the success of its
predecessor Shazam Fury of the girls was
met with dismal box office earnings
receiving only 133 million dollars on a
budget of around 125 million dollars
reviews weren't kind either combined
with Ezra Miller's numerous
controversies and the mediocre reviews
fans may have found it easy to pass on a
Scarlet speedster's Adventure after
remembering some of DC's latest
cinematic outings another reason that
the flash isn't performing well is that
Spider-Man across the spider verse was
released on June 2nd and this impressive
run at the box office are still going
strong as of the making of this video
the film has reportedly raked in close
to 500 million dollars and not too
surprisingly the Webhead is proving to
be tough competition for everyone at the
box office not just the flash Disney and
Pixar's Elementor was also released on
June 16th and is facing similar
struggles at the box office with an
estimated budget of 200 million dollars
the Pixar flick reportedly debuted at
only 29.5 million dollars it looks like
Elemental and the Flash might be on the
same leaky boat and the Rascal Miles
Morales might be partly to blame it'll
be interesting to track the flash as it
tracks to its days in theaters it still
has time to make some type of financial
Splash but it's not looking good so far
[Music]